[Música]
en la jornada inaugural de la cumbre del
g7 del anfitrión el primer ministro
británico ahora johnson indicó que los
líderes discutirán la donación de mil
millones de vacunas contra el cob y 19 a
los países más necesitados plan que ya
ha sido calificado de lento y poco
ambicioso por activistas
doble revés para la candidata
presidencial peruana keiko fujimori que
denuncia un supuesto fraude en los
comicios la oea descartó la existencia
de grandes irregularidades durante la
jornada y el jurado nacional electoral
reverso su decisión de ampliar el plazo
para presentar nulidades de votos sin
embargo aún no se anuncia al ganador de
las elecciones tenemos información desde
lima
ante la comisión de la verdad el ex
presidente colombiano juan manuel santos
pidió perdón a las víctimas de los
llamados 'falsos positivos' un caso en
el que miles de civiles fueron
asesinados y presentados por el ejército
como guerrilleros muertos en combate el
ex mandatario pidió que estos hechos
nunca vuelvan a ocurrir
gracias por continuar con nosotros en
france 24 soy valentina torre sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos damos inicio al
informativo en cornwall es donde inició
la cumbre del g7 con gran expectativa en
este en reino unido el país anfitrión es
el primer encuentro presencial entre
varios líderes mundiales que se realiza
de manera presencial desde que empezó la
pandemia
la cumbre tiene la vacunación contra el
cob y 19 y la lucha contra el cambio
climático como puntos principales de la
agenda además es el primer viaje al
extranjero del presidente de estados
unidos joe biden desde que llegó a la
casa blanca más romeros nos cuenta más
vuelven a verse las caras por primera
vez desde el inicio de la pandemia los
líderes del g-7 se reunieron en
cornualles reino unido- para la primera
cumbre presencial en un año y medio que
durará hasta el domingo
es que nuevamente maravilloso ver a todo
el mundo en persona marca realmente una
diferencia
y precisamente por eso la vacunación
global es el primer tema en la agenda se
espera que los líderes de los países del
g7 que son estados unidos canadá reino
unido alemania francia italia y japón-
anuncia en la donación de 1000 millones
de dosis de vacunas para los países con
menos acceso a los fármacos espero
obtener muy buenos resultados para
mostrar que no sólo pensamos en los
otros sino que también pensamos en esos
que no han tenido la oportunidad de
vacunarse además los mandatarios tienen
como objetivo acordar un plan para
enfrentar futuras pandemias el cambio
climático también es uno de los temas
prioritarios organizaciones sociales
convocaron manifestaciones en las
inmediaciones de la cumbre para
presionar a los líderes mundiales a
tomar acción contra el calentamiento
global este encuentro también supone la
primera escenificación del presidente de
eeuu joe biden de su nueva estrategia
global con el objetivo de reestablecer
los lazos entre eeuu y la unión europea
castigados por su predecesor donald
trump
by denny ya invitó a la canciller
alemana angela merkel a la casa blanca
mediados de julio
el viernes se cerró con una cena con la
reina de inglaterra isabel 2a y el
sábado será un día de reuniones
bilaterales a las que se sumarán países
invitados como india corea del sur y
sudáfrica
vamos ahora a perú donde la organización
de estados américanos oea descartó la
existencia de graves irregularidades en
la segunda vuelta de las presidenciales
celebradas el pasado domingo como lo
había denunciado la candidata keiko
fujimori que va perdiendo en el conteo
por un muy estrecho margen
la candidata por el partido fuerza
popular keiko fujimori con el candidato
de perú libre pedro castillo destacamos
la coincidencia de ambas candidaturas de
no proclamarse ganadores hasta que se
hayan resuelto todas las impugnaciones
de respetar las garantías del proceso y
a la institucionalidad electoral peruana
y de reconocer el resultado electoral
una vez desahogadas la fase
jurisdiccional de la elección el anuncio
de la oea se produce poco después de que
el pleno del jurado nacional electoral
reversar a su decisión de ampliar el
plazo para recibir nulidades de actas
electorales dicho periodo finalizaba el
miércoles y la reversa del organismo se
produjo tras una enorme tensión y
críticas del candidato pedro castillo
desde el imán nuestro corresponsal
francisco zacarías tiene los detalles
en perú se encendió la polémica porque
el jurado nacional de elecciones decidió
extender el plazo para presentar nulidad
de votos hasta las 8 de esta noche sin
importar que legalmente el tiempo había
vencido el miércoles esto genera una
reacción inmediata en el partido de
pedro castillo que movilizó a sus
simpatizantes a nivel nacional para
realizar plantones en algunas calles del
país así como también como en algunas
sedes del jurado nacional de elecciones
tiene baluarte postulante a la
vicepresidencia por pedro castillo acusó
al tribunal electoral de manosear
supuestamente la voluntad popular
ampliando el plazo en complicidad con
keiko fujimori y afirmó que la decisión
del organismo electoral constituye una
amenaza de golpe de estado ante la
presión mediática el jurado nacional de
elecciones y un paso atrás y dejó sin
efecto a la extensión de tiempo para
recibir los recursos de nulidad este
nuevo escenario afecta a la estrategia
de keiko fujimori y sus asesores legales
porque el plan era presentar 800
recursos de nulidad para invalidar
200.000 votos y conforme señalan algunos
colectivos sociales sólo pudieron
presentar cientos
hay una impugnación es que en el peor de
los casos le restaría 40.000 votos a
pedro castillo y a pesar de eso él hasta
ahora conservaría el primer lugar de la
segunda vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales en perú vamos ahora a
colombia el ex presidente juan manuel
santos pidió perdón a los familiares de
las víctimas de los llamados 'falsos
positivos' casos en los que miles de
civiles fueron asesinados por el
ejército y presentados como guerrilleros
abatidos en combate ante la comisión de
la verdad instancia creada como parte
del proceso de paz con la ex guerrilla
de las farc el ex jefe de estado confesó
que siente remordimiento por lo ocurrido
y admitió que la presión y los premios
por lograr bajas fueron un gran
incentivo para los militares en febrero
pasado la jurisdicción especial para la
paz aseguró que seis mil cuatrocientos
dos civiles fueron víctimas de esa
práctica
en honor a la verdad tengo que decir que
el presidente uribe no se opuso al
cambio de esta nefasta doctrina que él
mismo había estimulado nunca recibí una
contraorden ni fui desautorizado
pero me queda el remordimiento
me queda el hondo pesar
que durante mi ministerio
muchas
muchísimas madres
incluida en las de soacha
perdieron a sus hijos
por esta práctica tan despiadada
lo reconozco
y les pido perdón
a todas las madres ya todas sus familias
víctima de este horror
desde lo más profundo de mi alma en
otras noticias en la región etíope del
tigre de la onu pidió al gobierno que
garantice el acceso humanitario
ilimitado ante la hambruna inminente el
organismo que alertó que 5,2 millones de
personas necesitan asistencia
alimentaria de emergencia también llamó
al cese de las hostilidades que
iniciaron en noviembre pasado para
ampliar este tema nos acompaña susana
mangana ella es directora de la cátedra
de island de la universidad católica de
uruguay y analista internacional señora
mangana qué tan difícil es la situación
que enfrenta actualmente la región del
tigre
muy buenas noches efectivamente estamos
asistiendo a una nueva crisis
humanitaria activa catástrofe y
alimenticia es decir faltan en dos
dietas para al menos 60 ciento de la
población de la región de tigray
saltando de 2,5 millones de personas que
están envueltos en esta guerra civil
entregó tiempo federal de etiopía y la
región reviste independentista de tigre
y continúan los bloqueos y las
dificultades de acceso y hay acusaciones
a las tropas eritreas que respaldan a
los líderes del tigre de usar la
hambruna como un arma de guerra
efectivamente recordemos que tanto
eritrea como etiopía estuvieron
enzarzados en una guerra entre países
críticos de más de 20 años de hecho el
primer ministro etíope había allí
el premio de la paz en 219 gente por sus
esfuerzos por lograr pacífica y en la
región y sobre todo establecer la paz
con eritrea eritrea responde
militarmente apoya al gobierno federal
de había gente en etiopía pero parte de
los ciudadanos de lo que es la región
independentista de tigre y están bajo
mandato de eritrea
qué hace actualmente la comunidad
internacional ante esta problemática y
que debería ser para evitar una hambruna
masiva hay suficiente interés donde la
comunidad internacional por esta crisis
no justamente con lo que estás poniendo
el dedo en la llaga cuando preguntas por
el interés de la comunidad internacional
creo que la comunidad está realmente
absorta por salir de la pandemia por
esta carrera por las vacunas y no ha
prestado la debida atención a esta
guerra civil entre la región de tigre
y el gobierno federal de etiopía y ambas
partes son culpables de producir esta
hambruna que es fabricada por el hombre
dijéramos así porque no permiten la
llegada de la ayuda humanitaria
distintas agencias de naciones unidas
como la fao o el programa mundial de
alimentos o unicef denuncian que si no
se consigue alimentos rápidamente
muchísimos niños muchos menores van a
morir de hambre de hecho escasean los
alimentos en los hogares de tigray y
sobre todo lo que lamentan es la falta
de ayuda no sólo humanitaria sino
también de financiación para poder
presionar también al gobierno federal de
etiopía para que permita la llegada de
ayuda humanitaria mientras tanto el
gobierno de ahmed niega que exista
hambruna pero culpa de todo ello a los
rebeldes como los llaman ellos
señora mangana muchas gracias por su
análisis y por acompañarnos en france 24
en otras noticias el primero de julio
entrará en vigor el pasaporte comida en
la unión europea un documento que indica
si un viajero comunitario ha sido
vacunado ha pasado de la enfermedad o
posee una prueba pcr negativa este
viernes los 27 países miembros
recomendaron un relajamiento de las
restricciones a los viajeros vacunados
que ya no deberán estar obligados a
hacer cuarentena en los países destino
el informe es de rodrigo sedano
imágenes largamente esperadas por
turistas y comerciantes los destinos
turísticos europeos esperan una
temporada de verano con restricciones
laxas al turismo nacional e
internacional un hecho que está más
cerca de hacerse realidad tras el
acuerdo al que llegaron este viernes
embajadores de los 27 países de la unión
europea de anv stage los estados
miembros acordaron en esta recomendación
que los ciudadanos totalmente vacunados
y recuperados deberían estar exentos de
las restricciones relacionadas con los
viajes también acordaron una validez
armonizada de 72 horas para los tcp cr y
48 horas para las pruebas rápidos de
antígenos entonces la recomendación de
esta relajación de medidas entrará en
vigor junto con los certificados kobe
del próximo 1 de julio en ellos estará
indicados el viajero ya está vacunados y
pasó el virus o si tiene una pcr
negativa sin embargo desde la o ms
alertaron del peligro de las
relajaciones
deberíamos también recordar que estar
vacunado no evita de manera automática
enfermarse o contagiar el virus ante
este posible riesgo de expansión del cob
isla unión europea ha preparado el
denominado freno
emergencia con el cada país podrá
prohibir la entrada a viajeros de
regiones que registren un aumento de las
variantes más infecciosas del virus una
medida que aplica a viajeros de países
comunitarios miembros de la zona
schengen y países extracomunitarios que
ahora también podrán viajar a la unión
europea si ya han sido totalmente
vacunados naciones unidas advirtió de la
catástrofe de los derechos humanos que
viven mianmar desde el golpe militar del
primero de febrero al menos 860 civiles
ha muerto a raíz de la represión
policial calva santana tiene los
detalles
el conflicto entre la junta militar de
mianmar y los civiles opositores sigue
vivo con represión militar prácticamente
a diario cientos de muertos y miles de
arrestados desde el golpe del 1 de
febrero ahora el país asiático enfrenta
una intensificación de la violencia algo
de lo que naciones unidas advirtió y
calificó como una catástrofe de los
derechos humanos vino al sur y las
detenciones masivas de activistas
periodistas y opositores al régimen han
continuado en todo el país y fuentes
fiables indican que al menos cuatro mil
804 personas permanecen detenidas
arbitrariamente la alta comisionada
también está profundamente preocupada
por los informes de tortura detenidos y
castigos colectivos a los familiares de
los detenidos
cuatro meses después del golpe los
enfrentamientos se han recrudecido en
varias regiones del país como calle a
chin kachin y ante los abusos de fuerza
de los militares acusados incluso de
utilizar a civiles como escudos humanos
y de torturar a detenidos algunos
ciudadanos están entrenando para
conformar las
las fuerzas de defensa además alrededor
de 800 militares birmanos han desertado
en su mayoría para unirse al movimiento
de desobediencia civil por su parte la
junta sigue centrada en tumbar a los
símbolos de la resistencia como la ley
there and sand such y contra la que han
interpuesto denuncias por delitos de
corrupción y abuso de poder ahora ella
tiene un juicio previsto para el lunes a
pesar de sus intentos los militares no
han conseguido controlar el país con un
conflicto que ha dejado a cientos de
miles de desplazados
llegamos así al final del informativo a
ustedes gracias por su sintonía los
invitamos a ampliar todas las noticias
en nuestra web france24 puntocom
volvemos en breve a quien france24
[Música]